hey i'm new york nico and i'm sam
morrell and we're the guest judges on
pizza wars this week we're kind of like
judge judy but with bigger hogs
[Music]
[Music]
few foods tuck on the heart quite like
the grandma slice reminiscent of the old
school pan pies grandmothers would cook
at home grandma pizza is a new york icon
and a certified comfort food classic i
can't think of anyone better for a
grandma pie showdown than norma knepp
norma told herself how to make pizza at
home more than 10 years ago and went on
to win some of the pizza world's most
prestigious awards our judges today are
new york nico and stand up comic sam
morel these guys are new york natives
and really love their grandma slices so
you know i need to bring my a game
[Music]
norma i'm so happy that you're here
thank you so much for joining us i'm
nicole i'm so happy to see you again
it's been so long so norma your story is
very very interesting you started the
roots country market in pennsylvania
tell us a little bit about that it was a
lot of luck my husband i had a caramel
corn stand at market for a lot of years
his parents had it since 1928 a pizza
stand became available because they
never had fresh pizza there and the
market master asked me norma can you
make uh fresh pizza i said nope i said
about mine i said i learned so anyway i
went on pizzamaking.com and that's how
i'm going to make it making.com no way
yeah then i went on to win a computer
cup and i don't know how that happened
oh my god how big of a deal is that
that's a very big deal that's one of the
biggest things to win the caputo cup
yeah it's better than this
so today's challenge is all about the
grandma pizza why was the grandma pizza
the pizza you wanted to try today i
never really wanted to try it to about a
month ago
my daughter lives in brooklyn now my one
door and we were coming down 78 and we
stopped to get guests but yeah i saw
there's a pizzeria there and i looked
into pizzas they had new york style and
they had grandma the grandma's pizza was
delicious it was good it was delicious
and i never really tried it anywhere
else before what makes this a grandma
pizza it's a grandma pizza because it's
thinner than a sicilian you know
grandmas made this kind of pizza years
ago just like they made sicilian pizzas
the pizza i had was really thin like a
new york style it tasted something like
it but it tasted all together different
okay norma i cannot wait to try your
pizza so go ahead take us through your
pizza what i did was boil the pan and
then you try to stretch the dough out to
fit the pan then i put some garlic on
top of that first thing i'm going to do
is spread the mozzarella and other
cheese right on top here and put it
pretty close to the edges because i
don't want the edges to puff up a lot
something interesting about grandma
pizza's cheese goes down first before
the sauce that's right yeah and next
we're going to put the stick oregano
that i took off the stick this is a
crinkles a greek oregano and now i put
my tomato sauce on it's in dollops okay
now i'm just going to drizzle a little
olive oil over the top it's just
nice melt the flavors together it's
about ready to go in the oven okay
[Music]
pizza's out of the oven looking so good
oh thank you corner slice for me i
corner size for you alrighty oh i like
the way this looks it's like thin and
crispy and then the sauce is just a
perfect amount for a bite cheers to you
thank you so much
it's hot mmm
oh my gosh it's so good it's so crispy
it could be crispier on the bottom
crispy adding this yeah it's so good
well
i think my dough should have been
thicker the dough wasn't um enough for
the pan i don't think so
it's okay it's not what i wanted you
know what norma sometimes we are our
harshest critics despite everything
you're saying i think your pizza it's
amazing oh thank you so much nicole so
norma i'm up next it's going to be my
very first time making a grandma pie oh
my are you ready i am ready okay i'm
anxious to try it let's see what happens
okay
norma your pizza was excellent thank you
nicole guess what i'm making today
grandma pizza with meatballs that's
right i made this a little sundae sauce
i'm so excited
so i've seen some people make grandma
pizzas before and usually they make the
cheese go to the edge and yours is
really tasty with the cheese of the eggs
so i don't know if i'm about to make a
big mistake but i'm going to leave a
little crust around mine i'm just a
crust girl you know i don't think
there's any one certain kind of grandma
pie different places make them different
ways i'm putting my sauce down and i'm
just going to go across i'm going to put
some fresh mozzarella down this is gonna
be like a little placeholder for our
meatballs so we have our beautiful
meatballs they're equal part ground beef
ground veal and ground pork i'm gonna
slice these meatballs in half so
everybody gets a little bite i'm a
savory and sweet girl so i'm just gonna
throw a little roasted red pepper all
over this sometimes i'm doing too much
norma i haven't seen a grandma pie like
this in the city but you know this is
what i'm known for i just gotta take it
up a notch so i got the sauce down the
meatballs down you ready for me to put
it now i'm ready all right let's see
what happens
[Music]
oh oh my that's nice and crispy and
everything it does so what i have here
is a little bit of sweet tinned with
honey ricotta and i'm just going to give
a little scoop to each one i'm going to
put some of this beautiful translucent
fried basil on top and then i'm just
going to finish off with a little
pecorino that's my grandma ready
beautiful i'm ready cheers norma cheers
thank you so much for making such a
beautiful pizza i'm gonna get a little
ricotta on mine
you gotta have the meatball okay
delicious now the meatball is insane the
crust is very tasty you can tell it's
the longer fermented days in a day the
meatballs are delicious the basil is
very creative the cheese is good i give
this a really good rating thank you so
much it tastes very good norma we had
two delicious grandma pizzas today but
are we ready to go to the judges table
not me
i don't feel like i'm ready either i
have to tell you our two judges today
we've got new york nico and comedian sam
morrell great dude are you ready do you
know those guys well i don't know
impersonation i heard of them welcome to
peace awards
[Music]
all right let's do this first slice
let's go
[Music]
yeah i went all in i look disgusting
right now off really though
that's a good meatball too what do you
think
a little sloppy
the cheese a little sloppy i mean
everything together you can't i mean
what are you supposed to eat it with a
knife and fork i'm not trying to pull
the de blasio on camera i like the
meatball a lot um i am vegan i'm kidding
i'm not the meatball is great
it's enormous though i want smaller
pieces you know i like the crust the
crust is really nice
like i said it's kind of sloppy it's
already falling apart you know this is
like my body on the beach that's what
this slice is
i feel like the proportions are
everything you know you don't want to
have too much sauce you don't want to
have too much cheese you don't have too
much dough so that's that's the most
important thing to me i finished this
i'm still hungry i want to keep eating
i'm starving i pop my lactate i'm ready
to go for the rest of the day oh yeah
so this is our second slice
um that's good i could do with a little
less sauce on top here but it's it's
good a little too sweet for my liking
but maybe that's just because i got a
big bite of sauce but come to think of
it it's not very evenly dispersed what
do you think um i like how cheesy it is
i think a little burnt cheese here at
the end but yes a lot of sauce so the
sauce on top is a very bold that's what
makes it the grandma right
otherwise just the sicilian well i
always thought that the difference
between the sicilian and the grandma is
just the amount of dough the grandma is
thinner
and the sicilian they let it rise for
longer
crust is great yeah it's good it's just
too saucy but it's i like this one this
one's a little more manageable
[Music]
nico sam norma and i worked so hard on
our pieces today it was so much fun
working with you laura oh my god working
with youtube it's good to have you oh
thank you okay guys
tell us what you think both were you
know
they had their moments you know the
first one the meatball just overwhelmed
me the meatball was delicious
i mean if we had those in little tiny
meatballs then we both could agree
they'd be you know fantastic i think on
both there was too much sauce which like
i don't know if you ever had sex and
there's too much lube it's kind of like
that wait who complains about too much
lube have you ever heard too much no i
don't know this is you take me out okay
well i'm telling you too much is is not
good either a little bit's good i had
the same issues as sam i feel like the
the first one was a little sloppy it was
falling apart in my hand like he said it
was very hard to get to the meatball i
didn't even get a bite of it i had to
like it was like trying to find the
clitoris i was like what are we doing
this is insane the crust on both of them
were phenomenal okay we can't take it
anymore norma and i we can't wait who's
the winner
[Music]
pizza number two which is also what i'm
going to be taking after eating both of
them
your pizza was so good no no no you
can't beat a grandma and a grandma says
i know that's right there's nothing left
to do but to give this to you thank you
so much
thank you she's so sweet
oh it's so beautiful i think this is the
most beautiful thing i think so too when
they open it
oh
neat this is really special though
everybody's been so nice to me here
oh i'll be proud of this forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shhh
you